ready thank you for having me here I'm
fires on fornia and I'm from Stanford so
today it's my honor to give a talk about
principle minimum winning coalition from
marginals to joint distribution so this
is a joint board with mace I'm resident
who is a postdoc membrane of group
shearim cannon a former postdoc in a
group and now is an assistant professor
in use of Washington and it's supervised
by my advisor professor day we share
okay so let me start with this
genome-wide Association studies example
so here we have this data set it's a
data so that we know these snips and
genome sequence for let's say 1,000
individuals so we are working with a
high dimensional setting the number of a
snip is something three million and now
the question that we may ask here like
how to model this data by a joint
distribution so when we say that we can
estimate a joint distribution through
the data set but it's not the right
apples because the number of sniff
sequences is three to the three million
which is so large it's basically
infinity okay so an approach to do this
is we can find some lower the marginals
from the data hub so we can estimate
them reliably and then we go through
this step and find the Joint
Distribution submit a joint distribution
that agrees with this loader marginals
and represents our data for I mean
modeling goals so our focus in this talk
is on this step from lower marginals to
join distribution when I study what's
the right way in order to find the Joint
Distribution from this load margins okay
so for an unsupervised learning setting
we can have this principle maximum
entropy basically what it says is to
pick the distribution maximizing Shannon
entropy subject to the subject to this
distribution lies in Class C so low
order marginals will characterize a
class of June Joint Distribution see I
agree with this lower the Martinez and
then we solve this optimization problem
we'll have a joint distribution he so
prints for maximum entropy tells us to
pick the bond that we have the most
uncertainty under so it's the least
community distribution that we can have
here okay now let's change this example
a little bit here we add a trade boy
let's say we want to use this data set
in order to predict this file so this
way I can be diseases type of diseases
type of trades like breast cancer no
breast cancer or ribbon on this is a
type like handedness whether you are
left hand or right hand so in this case
we can see that's more sensible if we
want to use the philosophy of principle
maximum entropy to define a dependence
measure and minimize this dependence
measure between x and y on all Joint
Distribution that lies in class see the
class see that satisfies our lower
margins so basically the reason is that
here the role of x is different from the
role of this excise so we want to use
this excise in order predict by and then
we maximize joint entropy of XY we don't
consider these difference between their
role okay now the question that we may
ask each Mitch measure of dependence to
minimize so in the last slide we have a
general measure of dependence d now the
question is which measure of the
dependence that we can minimize it so
the one that would be suggested by
Shannon entropy is mutual information
and it's in fact the subject of this
2004 work by glob arson and teach by and
the problem the issue with this mutual
information is that we don't have I mean
there doesn't exist any efficient
algorithms that can find the
distribution minimizing mutual
information so for its computation we
have some problems so we talk about
other measures of dependence so I mean
one can be Pearson correlation
coefficient it's the most well-known one
in statistics and most unknown on in
most office of study but the problem
with Pearson correlation coefficient is
that it's not label invariant if you
change the labels the value of Pearson
correlation coefficient would change so
rainy observing this issue he suggested
this metric rainy maximum correlation
and this metric is to take the maximum
of Pearson correlation coefficients over
all functions F G that we can define on
X Y so in this way we can address
nonlinear dependencies between X Y and
it can be seen that this measure that
find the 2f and GS that maximizes the
correlation of this tool are under this
function we satisfy several properties
throughout desired properties so that
the first thing is that it's between 0
and 1 if X 0 if and only if example are
independent and it would be one if they
exist a function of 1 to be equal to the
order and last is that Lenny correlation
between to jointly Gaussian distributed
random variables would be equal to their
absolute value of the Pearson
correlation coefficient and is
consistent with the fact that once to
jointly Gaussian distributed random
variables become a uncorrelated from
each other then they are independent as
well
so now based on these desired properties
we asked what about principle minimum
any correlation so now we pick the
distribution P that minimizes any
correlation between x and y under this
distribution so we want to solve this
optimization problem so we have to add
as two things about this optimization
problem first analytica structure of the
minimizer so we have to see what kind of
structures are there in the distribution
that minimizes any correlation and
second is the computation so we need
some algorithms to compute the DC what
the distribution minimizes any
correlation first let's start finding
the distribution minimizing any
correlation for rather simple case we
change to the continuous case in order
to have some intuition about the
structure of distributions that
minimizes to any politician here you
have real valued x 1 to x p and x 2
suppose that we are given first and
second order moments so for this vector
X Y you are given this mu and lambda the
first and second order moments another
question is in this class of
distribution what is the one that
minimizes when the correlation and the
answer is it's not hard to show that
joining Gaussian minimized and collision
this class so it's simple to show that
it happens if we go over the proof the
key property of jointly Gaussian that
helps us to prove this result is the
linearity of conditional expectation so
this linearity this a structure helps us
to prove this result now we ask is the
same thing holds for the discrete case
or not so let's shift to the disk reset
here we have this kid excise without
loss of generality suppose it takes on
values in this set 12 m and we suppose
that Y is a binary threat as we had in
the g one sec so it's what we suppose
here now instead of moments let's say
you are given second order first and
second order margin
equipment in the second order modulus
and they characterize a Class C of
distributions that I agree with this
give a margin so we have px px I'll XJ
and pxi wise for all values that you can
define on X I my and then using the same
structure it's not hard to show if the B
suppose there exists a distribution in
this class see with this purple a
structure then that distribution with
minimize rainy correlation so under the
existence of this distribution we know
that this distribution will minimize any
correlation and the minimum value would
be achieved by separable function f G
just recall the definition of rainy
correlation now let's say we suppose
that there exists such a distribution
now I want to provide you with the
recipe to find the conditional
distribution by given X I the recipe is
that we shift to indicator variables so
we have this vector X and we build this
vector of indicator variables like this
so as an example here we have this x1
for individuals in the G was setting we
shift to this indicator variables you
can see the connection between here and
now having this vector indicator
variables I find the minimizer z-star to
this optimization problem is basically a
quadratic optimization problem and this
q & F's entries are just based on the
purpose marginals so it's basically a
linear regression on indicator variables
as you see here so we do this linear
regression define H like this is a
separable function and now if that p
with separable conditional expectation
exist under that assumption the
conditional distribution of Y given X
would be exactly this edge
okay so so far we've suppose that there
exists a distribution with this extra
structure with this separable structure
now the question is under what
conditions it may exist so from here we
can find a necessary condition the
observation is that this probability is
between 0 and 1 so this edge should take
values between zero and one for all
access so even if we do not suppose p
with separable conditional expectation
exist in order for that p to be exists
this condition to should be satisfied
now this is a necessary condition the
question is whether it can become so
efficient or not and the answer is yes
so how to check whether this condition
holds we'll start with that recipe we
find a minimizes this or to this
optimization problem and then we form
this edge if for every X 1 to X P the
value of this H is between 0 and 1 then
this is a necessary and sufficient
condition that that distribution exists
and we are in the fine regime okay so
that's I let me repeat it again because
it's the takeaway message so we have
here a necessary and sufficient
condition under which we know that the
distribution that minimizes any
correlation have that separable
structure and under this assumption we
can compute it efficiently unlike the
case that we have a mutual information
so one may complain that checking this
condition would take an exponential time
but it's not since we have this
separable structure on edge we can check
this condition in a linear time and it's
just because of this separable structure
that we've observed in this edge okay so
so far we've discussed
the separable a structure under what
condition it may exist and what happens
if you'd exist but but we didn't I
specified for how many distributions it
may exist so consider this diagram you
have a ground truth distribution q you
are not aware of then our estimates
second-order margins q xixj QX are wise
and from them i form a class of
distributions CQ now the question is how
large is the subset of qs for which this
CQ satisfied as condition under which we
are in the find Reggie the best thing
that's so far we have which proved is
that for PE uniform there is an epsilon
such that for any Q in the epsilon
distance so it's a normal distance in
epsilon distance from p CQ contains a
distribution that sad that has that
separable structure so the measure of
the subset of distributions that it
would be satisfied under is not 0 the
probability is not 0 but it's the best
thing we have proof the an interesting
question is can we do can someone better
approve edges or better than and own ok
so so far we've talked about just the
structure how we can find the
distribution minimizing any coalition
now let's see an application here we
have valuable selection problem let's
say we want to select variables based on
this optimization problem so we maximize
any correlation between those variables
selected my based on this constraint
then the number of variables should be
less than K ok so our work pull this
lower bound for any correlation and we
know that it can become strike under the
additive structure assumption so we have
this lower bound so when we say instead
of having any correlation here and we
maximize this floor about which can
become tight now the result is that it's
the same as group lasso when you make an
empirical average when you do an mag
maximum likelihood estimation of the
impact of the pairwise probabilities of
the distribution so it would exactly
result in this optimization power and
it's group lasso so it's a justification
for group lasso using the principle of
minimum brainy correlation okay so it's
just an application so in this stock I
introduced principle of minimum rental
correlation as a counterpart for
principle of maximum entropy and
peaceful minimum mutual information we
saw that in the continuous case under
fixing first and second order moments
join the Gaussian is a distribution and
we learned a structure of distribution
through that result then we went to the
discrete case and we saw that if they
exist separately structure in the
distribution minimizing any correlation
then that separate structure
distribution hood would be a minimizer
distribution under the class that we
feel that we fix first and second order
marginals and then we provide an
efficient way in order to compute the
distribution the conditional
distribution minimizes any correlation
under that condition and we provide a
necessary and sufficient condition to
check where it satisfies and how to i
mean the size of that subset that it
will be satisfied under unless we
provided a justification and
interpretation for group Lazoo using
principle of minimum rainy coalition as
an application to see how can he how can
it be applied to learning a modeling
problems so that's it
if I have two questions perfect one
project that in the district is quite
confused or it doesn't understand under
that condition we can compute but it
would be always a lower bound I mean so
in that slide I didn't go details you
can still give at once fusion but
actually it's it doesn't minimize any
correlation but it provides us with this
lower bound on the value of minimum end
coach and that's why we had this
justification for last Oprah practice
the statistics pizza you know you don't
know they distribution when you're back
here it's like yes mated a diffusion a
plug-in in this but what we show this
like edge will be all other functional
so you first estimate that's lucky and I
optimized in general and these two
something babe far from the true star
hey you're sure so for learning goals
let's say you want to do maximum a
positive probability so you'll need a
conditional distribution so from entropy
or mutual information you can do these
goals but because of that we I mean feel
a need in order to estimate the Joint
Distribution estimated distribution that
we can achieve learning goals such as
classification feature selection honor
so I think that for that for those is an
estimating mutual information or entropy
would not be enough so for example
suppose a prediction setting we wanna
make predictions and you need I mean for
maximum a possibility you need the
conditional distribution by given X or
at museums any other questions
so have you looked at beyond the
additive structure assumption what if it
has mother non-linearity after there so
basically what we should what we need to
do let me go back to say so here we just
consider these features x1 to XP now i
can define some more features basically
i can for example i have x i won I can
consider X I for which is 4x2 and then I
can I may have the XOR of this tool i
added as a feature in my data set and in
this way i can consider high-order
interactions of excise and how they can
affect this file so that's a way that we
thought of in order to address this name
so in practice often you have some label
data and lot of unlabeled data right so
of the unlabeled data in our population
can shall you be used to save better
approximate Emma harness so yes just
question together cosa are you
mentioning the for every rule in the
picture here but if they do you know the
value of y but right after you will have
that you'll have lots of rows where you
know the exes but you don't know the
wires right you have the sequences of
many people but you don't know whether
they have cancer or not so we can use
them in order to have a better
approximation of the joint I mean the
excise marginals so we consider for
example x1 x2 marginal so we can use
them in order to have a better
approximation of tall but I think in
terms of the marginals of boy and others
they cannot be helpful yeah I'm assuming
this one they can use be used to better
approximate the marginals of expert do
you think that maybe slightly modifying
the formulation or something you can you
could potentially make better use of the
unlabeled data maybe we can do
prediction for those on label data and
then they'd be at food I'm not sure
about that just is an idea and we
discuss a lot of play I think that would
be interesting idea
I was wondering actually if if you can
say anything about you know more general
families of constraints or not just on
the first and second order marginals so
now we are working on this problem
specifically we have shown that in
classification problem if you solve this
distribution that minimizes any
correlation we can have a very good
pound on the maximum error that we can
make in the prediction problem but so
far the results that we have are just
based on these second-order margins but
we can I think extended to other cases
one way is to sue you for example you
can define features x1 x2 just
concatenate these two x one x two
together make a new feature and they add
to this so in this day you can have for
example third order and for all the
motions but still we are limited to this
marginal case but that would be an
interesting question together all right
thanks again